[Music]
what a dream story that is
self-supported player nor Capcom Cup
champion
facing your demon is often the hardest
challenge of all these guys got so much
history playing each other so in other
words it's another classical battle yes
it is yes you know this guy a punk is
the worst because both years he didn't
need the CPC spot at all and he's here
to get keep ID on more than lifting
trophies more than winning thousands of
dollars the true test of a champion is
being able to face their rival the
person who always stood just beyond
their limits and emerged victorious
because in the end we don't remember the
trail of foes our champion left in their
wake we remember the one player who they
could never beat the one player who
always pushed them farther and how our
champion brought them down
[Music]
[Music]
I don't was nobody's pick for a Capcom
Cup 2019
he had an insane bracket he played to
mid tier characters and his rival the
one player he just couldn't beat all
year was one of the tournament favorites
I played him it makes you feel like
you're just like the worst player to
ever play Street Fighter he definitely
makes you feel like you make a lot of
errors
it basically seemed impossible for item
to make it past the first few rounds let
alone win the tournament but in order to
really understand what made items run so
incredible you have to understand who he
is first after a bad breakup with an
ex-girlfriend item rebounded into Street
Fighter 4 and Marvel vs. Capcom 3 which
eventually turned into a love affair
with Street Fighter 5 and it's resident
Brazilian jiu-jitsu master Laura she did
a lot of damage and like I always tend
to like gravitate towards guys that do a
lot of damage because the last time I'm
playing the better it's really just
trying to liquidate people with health
bars
early on Laura wasn't seen as that much
of a threat but by season 2 she was a
Tara and I don't made his name known by
robbing rounds with her a 10 lb see one
of the most competitive weekly
tournaments in North America well he was
cleaning up until punk showed up to NL
DC
and both definitely taking ID on to see
the great gaga at that point punk was
considered the best player in North
America and one of the best in the world
he was a terror and I Dom was having
trouble with him but then at defend the
North 2017
I don't finally got one over on they
paced off time and time again but it was
Punk who almost always one walk up OH I
don oh I don't be careful UNK Sperry
much so as he get the throw
[Applause]
every time we played in season two I
felt like our gap wasn't like too far
apart I was felt like in season two it
could go either way but in season four
he was beating me a lot I kind of like
had like a mental block but I also
thought like all Karen's not strong it's
hard to beat Karen but he was like
really good and he was like really
making the character like shine
meanwhile Punk was becoming a household
name he was a sponsored player which
meant he could travel to tournaments and
gain experience playing against the very
best in the world over the course of the
season he became feared for his
incredible hit confirms his oppressive
pressure and his non-stop t-bag and I
don't
well I'd almost still hanging out in New
York he was winning locals and playing
in some smaller East Coast tournaments
but he wasn't traveling but I don't had
a good reason not to travel his time and
money were focused on school he even
turned down some sponsorship
opportunities in season two the start of
season two I was like a semester and a
half almost done with college so
obviously I didn't want to be like I
can't be sponsored flying everywhere
obviously because then like one time I
have a big exam or some some something
important coming up and I don't want it
asposed to be like oh but we need you in
Europe or something or we need you there
so that was in the beginning season -
now that I'm almost done with school I
like one semester la as the seasons went
on I Dom's main Laura got weaker but he
stuck with his girl figuring that there
was no way she could be weaker than in
season one then halfway through season
four he picked up poison to cover some
of her bad matchups oh he had a bar GG's
GG's he dominated a 1000 BC and defend
the north and east coast Throwdown but
he wasn't traveling which meant that he
just watched as guys like punk went
around the world to collect CPT points
punk was a favorite at any tournament he
went to an item
well the diehards knew about I Dom he
wasn't making any headlines but then in
2019
I don't started to travel more he wasn't
exactly flying around the world or
anything but he was attending more and
more tournaments outside of the East
Coast and quietly item had a pretty
incredible year maybe stats short
blocking the dough again the mix-up
barring some colossal drop but he just
goes up does the simplest combo that he
can find if you could have Michael
walking with it works but he could have
work with a sweet stop max
stays in a front stop there's no escape
oh no he didn't follow oh no ed that's
it that's it that's lights out that is
lifestyle he didn't even activate he
didn't even have to activate this man is
playing on another level he's playing
out of this world this is intergalactic
tactics this man is just fun he wasn't
winning from your tournaments but he
wasn't learning a lot and growing as a
player I see how people in different
reasons at first a game like I feel like
America plays one way Japan plays
another Europe plays another every
region has like their own take on Street
Fighter 5 and night is refreshing to see
but in almost every turn his demon Punk
had placed him despite all that is the
first part of this around its Punk in
the corner with the corner
he's so good at just being ready for
people to try to jump out of the corner
the one time he tries to hit a button on
wake up punk has the media attack all
ready to go Punk spent twenty nineteen
as the unquestionable king of the CPC
leaderboard he won dozens of tournaments
and amassed more points in one season
than anyone ever had he was unstoppable
and going at the Capcom Cup 2019 punk
was seen as the only na hope people were
hot on Japanese players like bone Chan
and taquito
so if I had any chance it was gonna be
Punk not I Dom who was facing down an
insane bracket stacked with some of the
toughest competition Street Fighter had
to offer most people didn't even think I
don't want to win his first round
Fujimura item historically these two
have played a few times
I like Fujima in the match despite I don
playing fantastic this year I think that
this is somebody who always comes in
really hot
his record at capcom cup is incredibly
good I I'm gonna go would you more the
strength of Fujimoto is too strong my
actual goal is to like not going to I
don't wanna just be like oh if I got me
the capcom cup and then he lost to
straightens out the tournament I
actually just wanted to win like one or
two matches so I did it looked at that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all of a sudden I'd all been taken down
three of the best players in the world
all of a sudden I tom was in top eight
actually is just one match at a time
every after I made one match at a time
but on the other side of the bracket
punk was well he was just doing what
punk does it goes right in a trigger
goes further in this Capcom Cup bracket
he blew through the competition even
dropping food Oh what are the best
players in the world into the loser's
bracket an item after a narrow win and
top eight over a phenom items next match
was set it was him versus Punk the man
versus his demon everyone had their
money on Punk but I Dom wasn't going
down without a fight
the district Aaron really gets
frustrated because of our usually game
into the corner again is it reaching and
there's the stun WA orrible situations
are being he isn't gonna be able to get
the cure this weekend
with a valiant performance
takes his place and you can see how much
it means to him the first game we played
it was pretty bad so like I had to
remember I wasn't playing against people
I've rarely played me I was playing
against the guy I play all the time so
that's when I I had to make this wish to
poison and it was just getting more
familiar about how I keep plays and
stuff I'd almost sent down two losers
but he'd already achieved so much more
than anyone expected of him he was
guaranteed top three sponsors would
probably be more interested in him and
he proved that he was more than just a
threat on the East Coast he was an
international competitor who deserved
respect but the tournament wasn't over
and item wasn't done just yet after
after I lost honestly I wasn't taking
more about grand final though thinking
like who's gonna be my losers finals
opponent
[Music]
[Music]
with yet another win over phenom item
was once again face to face with Punk
and at first things did not look so good
[Music]
that was crazy has to be reversed
[Music]
[Applause]
to
with a slot head against either but
that's when I Dom balanced back he's
selling his round at the attack Crouch
face was it commits
[Applause]
[Applause]
they should be from glory
one win away from winning his first ever
Capcom Cup and punk looked shook he was
dropping his combos his legendary
confirms were off I Dom was inside his
head he needs to stop him put in that
500 on the screen he hasn't done
[Applause]
throw in the stun is wrecking up
immediately
come on Jimmy swim
Wow
[Music]
people stand up and take about a girlish
the talent before
[Music]
I don't lifted the trophy as one of the
most unlikely champions and capcom cup
history
he wasn't just one of the lowest seeds
in the bracket he wasn't just playing
mid tier characters he played against
his demon twice and won but that didn't
magically end his mental block with
Caron it didn't change his life in
incredible ways it just felt him do it
yeah this tournament like it really
counted so that's why I feel like it's
more it's more important help even when
he got back home I don't was still
humble his family doesn't even know he
won a quarter of a million dollars a
homeless ain't in [ __ ] but nobody really
knows nobody nobody really watches the
tournaments that I attend to so like a
secret my little secret so most people
don't treat him too differently
obviously the crowded NL BC is happy
that they helped craft the Capcom Cup
champion and they're excited to play
against him every week I don't still has
one class left to finish before he
graduates and he still has no idea what
he wants to do with the Capcom Cup prize
money he doesn't know if he's gonna
travel more GoPro focus on getting a job
take it easy
he's got no clue he's just taking
everything moment by moment and while
that might not sound like an incredible
plan for the future it's exactly how he
won Capcom Cup he took everything match
by match until in the end he broke down
every barrier between him and glory I
like I do enjoy convenient it's really
fun to like see everyone and like go to
places you never been before but I'm not
sure it's kind of weird I never like
thought of it I'm more of a now guy I've
really been thinking like about the
future and stuff it's not happening yet
so I'll focus on it another time but
that's when I don't bounce back bounce
bounce back Boing Boing Boing bounce
back Boing Boing Boing some bounce back
[Music]